foreign
react and web components
how it is
how it could be
and as I understand it because we all
deal with the web and things are always
changing so I kind of like to just put
like a little time stamps because this
is as I understand it at this point
because there's more things that I'm
actually looking into that are pretty
awesome coming up and so I may give a
talk about that later
all right
so hi I'm Dwayne a JavaScript developer
Advocate advantage and I figured I want
to come and talk to you all about web
components so who's heard of web
components let's raise your hands and
stuff
oh very nice so I'm going to need y'all
afterwards to you know let me know who I
got wrong or your experiences and why or
why not you're using them and how are
using them so then I'm assuming who
hasn't heard of web components
all right cool oh then why am I here
giving a stock cool so let me know if uh
you find any value in this and how you
want to use it in the future what have
you all right so real quick how many
people are using react just curious
all right okay A good view all right
cool so then this will make sense of
folks all right so now if you've ever
used like the video elements or the
audio tag or the details element I
always found it interesting how just by
putting the tag and like a source for
the video element you get a fully
functional video player
you didn't have to create the play
button or the pause button or listen for
those events the uh the mute any of that
stuff it's all just built in I always
thought that was kind of Awesome
same thing like the audio tag or even
the details details low-key one of my
favorite HTML elements you get a drop
down just built in amazing stuff all
right that's just me I guess all right
but now imagine if you can create your
own elements
right
whatever you imagine being able to just
create something and you put it on a
page and it just works properly once you
kind of understand that everything
becomes like a web component
so I like to make a lot of projects
right sometimes too many projects
and for each one of those I wanted to
have an about page right but having to
create one individually for everyone
makes me not want to create anything and
I just want to make right and just make
it put it out there and so I was like
hmm web components what if I created a
web component and called it Dwayne
hyphen made to where I can put that on
every project and it's uh responsive so
it does what it needs to do I only need
to do the work one time and so what on
each project I just call an endpoint on
each one of the different projects fetch
the data about the uh project and I and
it will format everything the way it
needs to be
uh in the web component so I don't have
to worry about any of that stuff ever
again so I can create have the about
page and I'm good to go
so that's one of them being reusable is
one of the main reasons I really like
web components another reason uh is that
you can use the same web component for
multiple uses so kind of like the Swiss
army knife of like uh web stuff and so
another cool like element that I always
thought was amazing was the humble input
button just by changing the type you can
radically change the feel and the usage
of it anybody else thought that was cool
is it just me I'm the web nerd here this
is cool okay maybe all right but I mean
just like you have a button and we all
know working with date and time is just
terrible on the internet you get a
calendar that tells you the date that it
is now imagine having to do that
yourself
terrible and then there's time and
everything as well
and then we have the range and then this
one the color a Color Picker
I don't know how you do that in CSS
that's just um that just seems like a
lot so again I just find these things
fascinating
and I get to talk about them so along
with multi-use I like I said working
with time has always been like a pain
for me so I was just like I need to just
do this thing once
and I'll be able to use it in whatever
projects I need to as well so if you can
see like this Sunday February 20th thing
that's this web component here this
countdown timer 432 same web component
and then here also so I created this web
component to where depending on how far
in the future it is it will show you the
date and the time in your local time
zone
and then once it reaches a certain like
limit that you can set I do like 60
minutes it will turn into a countdown
timer
and then it'll count down to the time
where that's supposed to be again in
your time zone and there's like a whole
lot of time zone math stuff that I don't
want to get into again did it once it
works never have to do it again
so again multi-use and uh being reusable
two of the things that I really like
about web components and those are the
things that always kind of running in
the back of my mind as I'm doing stuff
like am I going to do this again
and if I can't if I'm going to do it
again will I do it in different ways or
what have you so that way for me makes a
re good use cases for turning something
to web component
now one of the coolest web components
I've ever seen is model Dash viewer
anybody seen this before
like yes you know how awesome it is so
without knowing any sort of 3D modeling
or having to worry about AR XR web XR
virtual reality none of that you get it
all built in and then you can just kind
of mess around and play with it this is
amazing now you may be thinking that's
that's that's cute it's a little low-fi
poly thing well they stepped it up they
actually scanned Neil Armstrong's suit
and it's it this is look at the
reflection in the helmet
that is so cool and so again so you can
see the bottom of the shoes it's kind of
amazing and so just to get it working
you import a little bit of JavaScript
because the browser doesn't understand
what model Dash viewer is that's just
not a regular element and so you need
the JavaScript to kind of tell it like
okay don't worry about it this
javascript's going to tell you what to
do with it and then just here you put
the model Dash viewer tag and then of
course we got to be accessible shout out
to enterada uh you put the alt tag and
then you put what it is and they even
have like a poster image and then the
source is the actual whoops the actual
uh model for it and then you get this
this is amazing it's not only for
viewing like cool web 3D uh models also
you can put it in webxr so that's
augmented reality and virtual reality
which are things that I've been a big
fan of as well so I was like I wonder if
I can extend this a little bit further
and so I created a webxr tic-tac-toe
game with voice chat
and so again I know nothing about uh
webxr I think it's cool it's a lot of
work and I'm not I don't have the time
to do that work now so I'm going to have
this web component do it for me and so
I'm just going to kind of play this
video really quickly so you can kind of
check it out because I if you want to
play afterwards let me know because it's
deployed and I'll you know you can beat
me in tic-tac-toe I have swag and if you
beat me I'll give you shirts or
something or socks all right so here's a
quick video so
so you can see right there on my tablet
I have like the uh virtual reality
version of it and then I'm also
recording through my phone so you can
also see the augmented reality version
and so what I'm doing is playing a game
of Tic-tac-toe and I'm sending the moves
back and forth uh through our bondage
apis and so I'm able to kind of keep
each uh
board in sync with it and so it's not
only is it cool to like see it but
you're also able to pass information
back and forth between it and so I again
I didn't have to worry about any of this
stuff it just worked and which was
amazing and then I think I'm gonna like
win at some point neither but there's
also uh you can enable audio chat
because there's nothing more than like
hearing the person you're beating like
squeal and so
all right so then that's that and then
it wins what have you all right cool
now professionally because we talked
about the stuff I did like personally
cool things that I thought would help
with web components uh so I'm a
JavaScript developer Advocate again
advantage and I handle a lot of the
client SDK stuff and a good use case for
that is creating like chat apps right
and so instead of having people having
to create the different uh like the divs
or the sections for their chat app I
figured well why not just Encompass
everything into different elements so
that each element is responsible for its
own actions and listening for events or
sending uh events and so like we have
the VC messages
and that it lists all the different
messages that are sent in the chat then
we have the VC members that takes care
of all the members who are there and if
they leave it removes them and if they
come in it adds them and then we have
the VC text input where it is you just
put in your text message and hit send
and then we also have the VC typing
indicator which shows like who's typing
while they're typing what's cool is now
let's say if you wanted the VC members
on the other side of VC messages if
they're just HTML tags so in your HTML
just move it to the other side and
you're good to go again you don't have
to worry about listening for advanced or
anything they all handle their own uh
tasks that they're responsible for so
that's another cool thing so there's
that uh
now another one uh this is actually like
the first one I created because uh like
typing in like numbers and like things
is kind of a pain because you have to
listen for every button or what have you
so I was like well to make it work with
our client SDK a little bit easier
because you can also like main phone
calls with our client SDK stuff so I
wanted to be able to have something
where people just put it on their page
and then you have a keypad so if you
want to make it make calls or maybe
enter in a code or what have you you
don't have to worry about it you just
put that there and it does what it needs
to do and so these are some of the
things I used uh openwc which is a
pretty cool uh like framework for
creating a web components it sets up the
structure for you and everything so that
if you're on a team everybody's on the
same page because there's a bunch of
ways of creating web components and so
you can explore and find something that
you find that fits your needs but if
you're on a team you know just remove
all the choice just everybody's on the
same page and we can get this thing done
and so openwc is pretty cool for that
and it uses lit which is like a a
rendering library for web components
cool stuff and then have all the
different properties and attributes on
there so that you can change the
placeholder that's the text here and
this this is actually in my uh thing
here this is working
because it's just a web page that I do
for my presentations and then we have
the method where you can create the
action which will turn this to the
canceled event and then we have some
custom events here as well
cool now you've been asking yourself
that's fine Duane that's good for your
little project little side projects must
be nice right you may be asking well are
web components a thing yet and I was
kind of asking that as well shouts to uh
Westbrook J on Twitter he put told me
about this website our web component's a
thing
yet.com and short answer yes
now I'm going to need some participation
here I'm going to scroll this page
and every time you see a logo of a
company that you recognize please say
ding
all right so you see a logo you
recognize
I know there's like a delay with the
translation
so you see a logo you recognize
all right cool so here we go
keep the things going
nice thank you thank you very much thank
you for participation
now let's talk more specifically
specifically about like YouTube a lot of
people use YouTube right if you ever
look at the source code of YouTube you
see all these random YTD things YTD
hyphen Rich hyphen grid hyphen row means
nothing to me but to them at YouTube it
means something and so that's a good way
of saying like oh that's a custom
element because I have no clue what that
is so it must be something meaningful to
them that's why it's a custom element
which is cool so yeah all throughout
YouTube
GitHub they actually created a set of
web components that you can use yourself
called time elements and so the way they
use it is that if you ever like push the
change or like did a PR what have you
it'll say like however many seconds ago
or however many time ago those are web
components you can see right here it
says like uh time hyphen ago
and so even GitHub is using it also in
their uh website
now what about browser support you know
do you need like the bleeding edge of
whatever random browser nah pretty much
any modern browser has support for web
components which is great all right and
then I have Source links you can check
out web components.org you know fact
checking
now so how it is with react not so great
now there's two main things that web
components kind of have to do they have
to handle data and handle events so the
data going into your web component and
then the events coming out of it now the
current react all data basically they
handle like attributes so they're
basically strings
so that's cool if you're just using
strings but let's say you wanted to have
like uh an array or an object
have you ever gotten that object object
thing the error which is just so
frustrating
so that's what's going to happen now
there's ways around it and you can do it
but it's kind of a pain and then because
of the synthetic events system I think
it's called you you can't just listen
for events coming out of like
uh elements normally you have to use
like use ref or whatever it was right
but now
this is how it could be
there's an experimental branch of react
how many people knew there was an
experimental branch of react
exactly that's why I give this talk
and so uh I like I'm just trying to try
and gain like like uh awareness and just
grow awareness that there's this it's
there like it's there for you and so
as you can see it passes everything
everything is great like even the uh
like the events you can have like was it
a camel case Pascal case snake case all
the cases and so it's fully supported
it's kind of Awesome
so I kind of want to talk about like
some of the benefits of full support and
I'm the type of person I always like to
think of others so I won't somebody
please think of the maintainers
because you have people spending their
time like their free time working on
projects to kind of make our lives
easier right so why have them work on a
full set just for react right and so
because I'm not talking about me because
with me you're gonna get a pretty good
uh like GitHub repo that explains
everything and how to use it and
everything even the diagrams this took
me a while to put together so you're
gonna you're gonna know how this works
right and then also I write blog posts
so using web codes and react so I talk
about all the ways from class function
to everything you uh hooks everything
all of it's here right
uh and you can always reach out to me on
Twitter uh we actually have like
Community channels Advantage so you can
uh reach out to us there I do workshops
and um but I'm talking about people like
Corey lavisca this is a hero he has this
really cool shoelace web component
library has anybody seen or heard of uh
or used shoelace
it's pretty awesome so that actually
that web that uh QR code that I showed
earlier that was the shoelace web
component you just put on there so if
you were looking to generate web
components easily this is uh pretty cool
but yes also it's kind of cool so I know
it's on the site so it's a
forward-thinking library of web
components right and it says works with
all Frameworks all these things we're
cdns blah blah blah what I noticed was
that first class react support and I was
like I had to reach out to him and so on
on the page look under react shoelace
offers a react version of every
component to provide an idiomatic
experience for react users uh you can
easily toggle between HTML and react
examples throughout the documentation
and you look at angular and view they're
literally the same sentence except you
replace angular and view plays nice with
custom elements you can use lace in your
angular apps with ease but you see how
there's all this other so I was like I
reached out to him on Twitter I was like
yo are you not bothered by having to
like recreate twice double your work
him being the nice guys like no you know
once I do it once it's fine it's no big
deal or what have you
but then he actually said one of the
biggest gripe is that he has to maintain
now two different examples with Demos in
the docs and so it makes working on
these things much slower so yeah let's
think of the maintainers now
what about yourself you gotta think
about yourself because I don't know
about you but it feels like sometimes
react makes you jump through hoops just
to use web components and if you like
this I might make it an nft and I'll put
it up so anybody's interested
kidding anybody Okay cool so sometimes
it just feels like you have to go jump
through hoops to get it done
so for example so this is I have links
to an actual working stack Blitz but
this is a piece of the code and so
that's that use ref that we spoke about
before because react doesn't have they
create their own synthetic event system
thing so now in order to get your a
reference to your element you have to do
use ref right and then you have to use
use effect to be able to add event
listeners to it and then you have to
return the things that remove the event
listeners and then this then you
actually have the web component here and
you can see the action text is just a
string and that's a string but if I had
to do like an array I would have to do
this other thing with the thing and the
current it's just a lot so there's that
but now how it could be that's it
you just put the element that's all and
then you just do the same thing and you
have the on digit hyphen added again
with these the snake case or however you
want to do it it's just that's it
there's no use ref there's nothing it's
just that so
uh with that said
yay
boo
all right thank you you have to kind of
like go like remember these things I'm
trying to make you know different ways
of remembering these things all right so
future proofing like I mentioned before
if you've used react you may have
remembered that just in version 16 there
was like three different ways of getting
a reference to your elements and you saw
before if they have full support you
don't have to worry about any of that so
future proofing is another option
and then also styling because you know
it's cool to have your elements and
they're all looking like but what about
styling everything right so there's a
couple of ways there's the CSS custom
properties who's used like it's also
called CSS variables who's use pretty
awesome right now the thing is is that I
have this I have this example here
button so you just set the button and
you have like a background color then
you have VAR and then you have your
variable that you want to use for it and
then like a uh like a fallback color
what have you now that's cool background
color what if you wanted to do the
radius well then you'd have like uh the
radius and then you would have like the
bar and then you have that well if you
want to do the font color then you have
the font color and then that and the
other thing and if you want to do like
font size and it's that another thing
whatever
you may forget something that you know
like you want the person to use or maybe
you don't want them to be able to change
it it's all up to you but there's also
the part
who sort of part
see that's awesome right super cool so
same example except you name your thing
you put part and then you just give it
the name and part so like button I just
called it button because that makes
sense but you can call it Isaiah I don't
know what color would you want
and uh so when your custom elements when
you define it you put custom element
colon colon part and the name of the
part
and then install it however you want
it's just that's it there's just do what
you got to do it's amazing so it's free
form which could be good or bad
depending on I like people have total
say whatever they want to look like
stuff so that's just me but if you want
to have some control you can use the CSS
variable stuff all right so let's take a
look at a couple of examples all right
so uh let's see here so this is the VC
uh text input so let's take a look at
HTML so you can see I just have a little
bit of JavaScript here so that you can
tell what to do with the VC text input
and then I have that placeholder again
so let's say you want to get aggro and
you really want people to know about the
placeholder text
and then uh hopefully there we go
all right now let's take a look at the
CSS
so again I'm just going to remove this
so you see VC text input button and
that's this here I don't know why you
want to look like that but again do what
you got to do it's fine I'm not here to
judge you
uh so yeah so you can see you can make
it look however you want uh next
now this is the VC members uh thing that
I was talking about before you know it's
kind of it looks classic look you know
it looks clean looks nice but now what
if you want to do
it's going to look that now that's rock
and roll that's just that's just awesome
and so uh so yes you can see I changed
like the list style disk I don't even
know what people even do that but I just
did it uh then we all right then also so
the part each one of these L I call it
Li because they're Li's and I just
change the color to Black and the font
side makes them larger now sometimes you
may have to run into issues where you
have to use custom uh CSS variables and
so for example I could not find a way to
change like the even and odd Parts here
using my part I just I don't know if
somebody knows away please let me know
but again as far as I understand it I
don't think there's a way and so uh so I
just have my you know BC members and
child odd color and then it's green and
then blue so I was able to set it using
that way so sometimes you may need to
use both it kind of depends
all right uh cool then here's the VC
keypad now check this out so how it
looks normally right just you know
entering numbers you know playing but
what if you wanted to turn it into like
a keypad like a Gamepad
and uh bam oh wait no no and so then you
can like you know pew pew and shoot
asteroids or whatever that is that you
want all right uh cool so
I think we're all here because uh we
believe in the web
so I am once again asking you to uh
believe in web components
and uh yeah so thanks for having me uh
I've created this random website because
again I create random websites and uh so
web components.in was available so I had
to buy it and so slash react for real
and that list that goes to the uh it it
has a link to the actual GitHub like
repo thing where they're talking about
the experimental version so if you could
like let them know like hey we I think
this is cool could we maybe you know
Rush this out let's get this working
because I like web components I want
full support you can let them know and
uh that's my website
and uh yeah and then uh that has a
dwayne.in Vonage has a bunch of links
and stuff to like how to use web
components in various things and um yeah
thank you
[Applause]